also leute dieses 40 stunden homer
simpson essen video geht jetzt zu ende
dass ich mir ein fucking donath bürger
reinziehen gibt durch den die leute
jetzt willkommen zum neuen video vom
kanal und letztendlich auch zu einer
neuen serien was ich heute in diesem
video machte habe ich vor in zukunft
öfter zu machen mit verschiedenen
personen er ab dem titel und dem verein
schon gesehen ich werde heute hat einen
tag planen essen wie homer simpson und
das kann natürlich auch sehr gut mit
anderen personen machen wie zum beispiel
harry potter oder in welche berühmten
schauspieler also wenn euch jemand in
die richtung reinfeld der auf eine sehr
interessante art und weise ist nicht
diese anweisung zuerst mal testen sollte
dann ab damit in die kommentare
ich glaube die allermeisten für euch
kennen homer simpson das ist diese gäbe
der ist die hauptfigur aus die simpsons
und ich darf jeder kennt die simpsons
und roma ist dafür bekannt dass er sehr
spezielle essensgewohnheiten hat ja das
ist jetzt mein einkauf für meinen pommer
simpson frühstück beziehungsweise
mittagessen
wir sind schon leute ich werde an diesem
tag heute sehr sehr sehr sehr viele sehr
ungesunde dinge essen ich werde viel zu
viele kalorien essen und schon hat mal
was du gemacht und natürlich auch wie
viele kilos ich habe zugenommen habe das
problem bei der ganzen sache jetzt ist
dass ich mich normalerweise recht gesund
ernähre also die 80 braucht also nicht
zu viel fett als sind nicht zu viel
zucker nicht zu viel kalorien am tag
diese thomas haben jeweils 450 kalorien
ein paket oder neue reihe du viel am
donath diesen 1200 kalorien
der musiker habe anders viele kalorien
hier noch mal 1200 kalorien
dann haben wir einem etat von dessen
auch noch 1300
wir packen erstens ist das überleben ich
habe für dieses video eine liste mit
hoffers lieblingsessen im internet
gefunden und wir checken ganz kurz mal
das was ich hier habe auch also
aufstellt wir haben hier hommers liegt
nichts ist nummer drei cops homer
simpson ist tot es zu hause beim
picknick oder im park daniel dieplinger
ist eine waffel von monastir wissen
schokolade und natürlich ganz wichtig
lieblingsessen nochmals sechs donuts und
aus diesen drei die prinzessin von
obergeschoss quasi mein frühstück mit
oft schon war aber nicht deswegen hoffe
ich dass mir das bisschen mehr
möglichkeit gibt es hier zu verdauen
ich musste so lachen leute also diese
dollar eingekauft aber supermarkt die
beschreibung von den dollar ist einfach
fällt gebäck mit fett glasur und schaut
zur kategorie also fett fett zucker also
ja aber das ist nicht das problem
das problem ist hier das grüne darauf na
ja das ist einfach in so eine after
eight monat mit schokolade zum insider
wer will denn so was
woher weißt du was ich glaube die
geilsten über alle angst
wie die stadt die stelle hier ist der
hier auch in geschmack und hat wieder
einen sehr hier hat gott sagen auch ein
bisschen schokolade und wenn sie denn
die mit einem ungesunden ist aber wenn
du diesen angriff
und geil hat der film enthält 114
gefüllt mit mir den weg wenn das
wirklich auch gar nicht ich habe so
lange keine dollar mehr gegessen hat es
schon jetzt können wir danach erstmal
diät um wintersport müssen oder scheiße
ich heute locker 5000 6000 kalorien
essen kann die übrigen sollte ich glaube
ich dass ich jetzt mal ein
kalorienzähler ein also die ersten dort
auch die letzte also sind wir soweit
sagen laut 49
das ist so viel wie in der carlo rienzi
fünf eisberg köpfe die zusammen vier
kilo wiegen
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das baby mach
ich esse auch ried ob die ja gar nicht
so oft ungesund ich es gar nicht so oft
ungesund aber wenn ich dann mal ungesund
essen
dann will ich so mein körper zerstören
dann will ich die künstlichen arm ich
will zucker ich will fertig will so
volker smid grace oder ich will damit
bacon bürger
rudi roloff preis und den fucking
deshalb spricht er mich am meisten
ausfüllt mit flammen gerieten sogar
liegen und so einen scheiß dollar womit
hier bisschen weg hat und die kalorien
hat dann gesagt ein ganzes eisbergsalat
mal zum vergleich so raus 80 kalorien
diese ist eine strip 400 also kannst 55
kilo salat esse ja und hass und kalorien
also kannst kannst nicht fünf chinesen
aber du kannst einen investor für flori
ich meine sachen den feierlich mehr war
der brand aus sieht dennoch noch fühle
ich mich gut nach einem soll ist noch
was anderes wenn das jetzt als neun
kilokalorien inhalt sondern eine minute
zu gewöhnen
also meine die so wie jetzt wenn der
mega frühstück das meer vortrags mache
warum nicht auch mal wieder in der box
ja aber in homer simpson ist glaube ich
bin wirklich der mensch dafür so sich
zwei donath reinzufahren in rückzug
kommt dann noch mal vier landtags ok
dann würde ich sagen komm zum herzhaften
teil des frühstücks ich hab' ich soviel
schon mal sagen ich habe mir schon was
richtig richtig perverses für entweder
das mittagessen das abendessen überlegt
sind beinhaltet auch downloads und dass
behinderte bürger aber sollte nachher
sehr passend dazu hat er hier schon mal
ein glas cola natürlich nicht sieben
oder leichter den richtigen kurs
eingeschwenkt ist schon eigentlich
thematisch das echt zuviel zwei donuts
und cola box soll leute wir haben hier
die software hot dog fans in die puppen
wir jetzt gleich hier einen wiener
würstchen rein damit müssen wir jetzt
noch mit ressourcen dritten liga warst
du wieder wirst du des instruments von
einer marke die ich kenne
liga neulings teil aus der drei stücke
oder bewusst vom 14
[Musik]
katharina gar nicht so eine wurst 150
grad 100 kalorien so wir haben jetzt
hier unser hauptmarkt und ich sag jetzt
bei chrome alles immer so ein bisschen
maßlos
das muss man alles bisschen übertrieben
zu viel sein deswegen mache ich mir erst
mal die würstchen warm und packt dann
mindestens zwei wenn nicht drei oder
alle vier enders bahn und wie andere
typische ja ja sag mal das like damit
trennt werden kostet zwischenbericht ich
merke gerade wieso die donuts in meinem
magen ankommt das maß nicht mit dem
guten gefühl bisher so gefühlt waren so
vorstellt jetzt geht's los und das
reicht auch schon wieder
wir müssen natürlich wird jetzt auch
nicht richtig durch erhitzen war er ich
meine oma ist auch teilweise so halb
gefrorene lebensmittel zu lax
lebensmittel sind die amag und jetzt
behörde glück und also zwei ist kein
problem mehr als auch kein problem
ich probiere die sachen pizzen und was
sagst du als ernährungsberater solche
fonds einzeln ersten oder alle versuche
das sieht schon sehr hoch aus wie
schauen wir uns also ich glaube ich kann
da nicht oder ein stück abreißen es geht
nicht aber ein gutes gericht und haben
ja ja aber wir sagen hier bei diesem
ist die konsistenz wirklich exklusiv ich
muss sagen es schmeckt fucking marek
belka walter schmeckt einfach geil ich
glaube darum geht auch ins koma teams
muss man seinen körper auch einfach ein
bisschen finden ja das möglich ich werde
so ganz kann zu nehmen also dass britta
hat 180 kalorien die würze 400 kalorien
sowie 600 kalorien dazu 800 curry von
den donots denn schon 1400 lustig oder
der kalorienbedarf dem normalen
erwachsenen und so 2000 ich habe beim
frühstück bei dem schon 1600 verläuft
und wie kriegt man sich vier wird dort
und ein brötchen später so da natürlich
vorteilhaft ihr wirklich schon normal
das problem wird jetzt habe ich nicht
die richtigen probleme
hier kommen es gleich wenn ich das alles
für dauer oder beginnen ist zu verlangen
dann wird man kann aber sagen ja 24 aus
cola ist nicht viel aber das war so
weitere frühstück hat der stabile 1006
an kalorien ich würde sagen ich möchte
mich gleich wieder wenn ich nur die
ersten auswirkungen auf meinem körper
spüre ob das jetzt eine stunde vergangen
sind beim frühstück und ja ich bin
relativ am sarg ehrlich gesagt ich
überhaupt keine energie ich ihnen die
ganze auf der couch für mich mega
aufgebläht ich merke auch wirklich wie
sich so meine muskeln zusammenziehen
habe ich das gefühl dass wir das können
leute aber man so sport macht seine
muskeln trainiert und dann viel eiweiß
ist lachs zum beispiel dass sich die
muskeln so auf und wenn man so ein
zuckerl scheiß im berner dann gehen die
muskeln richtig zusammen als es richtig
war jetzt durchziehen und ich freue mich
schon nicht auf das mittagessen okay das
ist jetzt zwei stunden seit dem essen
vergangen und mein körper dreht durch
habe ich das gefühl also wie gesagt dass
nur zwei stunden ich habe zwei stunden
1600 kalorien zu mir selbst für mich bin
95 kilo schwer war viel sport ist das
immer noch eine halbe tagesrationen okay
und ich habe jetzt schon wieder hunger
zwei stunden später nach 1006 kalorien
fühlte ich mich als hätte ich schon
wieder hunger aber ich kann eigentlich
keine haben oder also es geht nicht
maxis theorie ist das einfach das essen
nicht sättigt was auch sinn wat kann
nicht sein kann erklärt nicht so 1016
katholische prägung also ich könnte
spielen aber ich glaube heute das kann
ich eigentlich hätte ich höre zu essen
ich warte kurz mal ab und wenn ja wo er
an einer haltestelle wasser als dann am
nachmittag außerdem eigentlich ist der
sinn ja also von diesem wieder sich
jetzt schon dass wir das schlimmste das
ist so möglichst gesund ist und so nicht
geil
zwar wehrten sich jetzt auch klar dass
wenn sie überprüfen was ist nicht gerade
einfach so war auch entspannt ein paar
würfe wir gehörten ab jetzt gerade warm
und ist jetzt auch bekommen
nein ich okay wir haben jetzt 16 19 es
sind fünf stunden vergangen seit meinem
frühstück und ich habe immer noch nichts
gegessen und ich habe jetzt immer noch
nicht so wirklich hunger aber max und
ich mache aus da jetzt weg deswegen hat
man ja er ist mein onkel und meine tante
hat geburtstag verbrachte gerade noch so
büchel wurde ist nicht kann doch keiner
wissen wir dass klose muss nach bayern
fahren zwei stunden und ich muss schnell
meine homer simpson mittagessen zu mir
nehmen was man thomas simson wenn er
zwischendurch machen hunger hatten was
macht er da christian hock genau und
schnell hatte und zwar ganz wichtig wenn
es schnell gehen muss ist den ort ohne
etwas zu essen erstmals süden fliegen um
dort müssen die sache ist da ist also
ist nur noch ein 300 soll es davon
nehmen vier was keinem sein
ich fühle mich wirklich schlecht ich
fühle mich nicht gut ich bin aufgefallen
ich fühle mich schmutzig okay die zwei
downloads und die hot dogs heute morgen
habe ich schon wirklich ihren gezeigt
aber wenn man so jeden tag ist dann
schau leben also okay aber jeden fall
heute hier geil geil aus
[Musik]
endlich geht's gut
leider ja seinen plänen donath mit
hosting und sprinteten als ich dort viel
leckerer kann man den eigenen blutzucker
nicht [ __ ] und so jetzt erstmal
qualitätstest pocking geil kann ich
sagen die da so eine wurst aus dem glas
ist einfach das lifestyle hier leute
jetzt habe ich noch mein letztes stück
dauert das ich auch bewusst essen darf
aber wer heute domagala geilich bild
angefixt auf diesen der donner probe
okay ich bin angefixt ich brauche jetzt
schon eine dollar zu hilfe
wir werden hier auch mitnehmen nach
bayern gefahren und hat nicht zuletzt
die hauptbücherei und dann fahren wir
los und dann sehen wir uns nachher
nochmal fünf leute was ein stress wir
sind wieder zurück aus bayern in köln
der 3 248
ich habe hunger habe geisteskranken
hunger und ich habe erwartet und zwar
haben wir die liste mit homer simpsons
lieblingsessen eine sache hat natürlich
bisher gefehlt und zwar ganz kurzen
jetzt zu den tag über für dich mit dem
essen
scheiße
es ist wichtig so dass ich mich wirklich
den ganzen tag über schlecht gefühlt
habe ich habe mich aufgenommen gefühlt
ich habe es richtig an meinem körper
gemerkt wie es richtig auf den bauch
gelegt so auf und muskeln an seinen
körper gezielt sich so gefühl zusammen
man fühlt sich einfach ungesund und
schlau und dementsprechend brauche ich
mir jetzt das härteste mir von allen
gästen breit und zwar schaut hier thomas
lieblingsessen nummer zwei naja ist ja
relativ klar aber in kumpel von mir und
zwar luca nicht der youtube blogger ein
anderer aus unserem freiheitsgeist hat
mich auf das aufmerksam gemacht was wir
hier sehen
genau das jetzt auch machen zum
abschluss von dieser serie mittagessen
wir wissen wird mein abendessen jetzt
ein donnern mörder ein mist ich habe ihn
bei mcdonald's mcdonalds das ja auch
formel für rosberg
bei den simpsons und was jetzt passiert
leute was jetzt passiert wird er in los
so wir haben ihren big mac aber das wird
nicht lange normaler segment weiter ich
glaube wenn ich jetzt einfach mach mir
intel habe ich mir ein kleines messer
griff ich mir so nah packung gäbe dann
wird schon relativ klar
für alle die es jetzt geht oder england
noch mal schnell das sollte ja das
bestimmt schon denken können
das wird da sind meine ehre lose
amtshandlung aller zeiten auf youtube
ich sag mal wie es ist immer fährt hier
auch einen donut mörder und zocken uns
jetzt einfach mal hier
egal ob das was dazwischen
ich wollte diese soße das problem ist
damit seinen eigenen bruder diese videos
von max weiß genau dass ich diese soße
hassel man deswegen trägt damit zur iss
zusammen mit chris zwischen partie quasi
darauf dass zwischen brot sondern das
kann ich bitte aber das essen ich glaube
was anderes ist das lecker aus titeln
wie komisch aus ein bisschen giftig
vielleicht die sache ist sicher besser
drauf als wir gerade eben in bayern
waren auch nichts gegessen bei ich
musste erst die homer simpson immer
sprechen ist es jetzt glaube ich nicht
gar nicht so schlimm wie es eigentlich
wäre weil peter kurer habe aber ja also
leute dieses 14 stunden wie homer
simpson essen video geht jetzt zu ende
dass ich mir einfach gegen donath bürger
reinziehen gibt durch den ich bin werde
ich mal ein schicksal das sie weiß es
nicht
es ist zu viel das alles schmeckt ja
alles lecker essen aber wieso diese
große das schön nicht dazu oder schmeckt
ja es gibt klar
irgendwie ist es bei dem es nicht weiß
nicht warum so dass die geschmäcker so
nacheinander kommt meister und war es
entweder gerade donath geschmack im mund
oder burger geschmack und das wechselt
sich irgendwie ab und es störte gar
nicht so sehr was könnt ihr nochmal der
klassische team heute ohne dass ich
hätte nicht gedacht dass das halbwegs
akzeptabel ist der motionär weg mir noch
was da wirklich dieser tag hat meine
geschmacksknospen schon komplett auf den
kopf gestellt weil am ende des tages
kann ich einpacken burger essen ok süße
tour sicher dollar teure gurken und
fleisch dazwischen das wäre in meinem
vorherigen leben nicht denkbar gewesen
aber jetzt geht er zu malen schöne
nochmal wissen zum abschied und damit
nur noch eins geschafft schreibt meine
kommentare ob ihr andere person im kopf
hat mit denen ich mal so und 40 stunden
essen wie wir machen soll und checkte
drin meine vorgeschlagenes bieber das
war zu weit von mir ich bin froh dass es
vorbei ist